This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Six years ago, I was diagnosed with a rare, inoperable form of bone cancer called Condrosarcoma. A cancer I still have to this day. Elizabeth Finch used to be a writer on the popular medical TV show, Grey's Anatomy. Other writers said they deferred to her opinions while writing episodes, since, as a cancer patient, she was the authority on what patients were going through. I'll told my cancer cost me my hair, my immune system, one knee, half my bank account, half my thirties, and one functioning kidney.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。六年前，我被诊断出患有一种罕见的、无法手术的骨癌，叫做软骨肉瘤。直到今天我身上仍然带着这种癌症。伊丽莎白·芬奇曾是热门医疗美剧《实习医生格蕾》的编剧。其他编剧说，他们在写剧集时都会听取她的意见，因为作为一名癌症患者，她是经历过这一切的权威。我被告知，我的癌症夺走了我的头发、我的免疫系统、一个膝盖、一半的银行存款、三十岁的一半时间以及一个健康的肾脏。
I mean never be cancer free. But in a December 2022 interview with the Ancler, a newsletter about goings on in Hollywood, Elizabeth Finch admitted that her cancer diagnosis was a lie. One of her colleagues told the newsletter that Elizabeth Finch was someone who sported, quote, a visible chemo-port bandage who regularly took breaks to vomit, who only ate saltines for long periods of time, and who wrote and talked about her experiences all the time. We were unable to reach Elizabeth Finch for a response. Her story may seem extraordinary, but she's not alone in making false claims.
我的意思是，我可能永远无法摆脱癌症。但在2022年12月接受专注于好莱坞动态的时事通讯《Ancler》采访时，伊丽莎白·芬奇承认她的癌症诊断是个谎言。她的一位同事告诉该时事通讯说，伊丽莎白·芬奇经常贴着显眼的化疗端口绷带，经常因呕吐而暂停工作，长时间只吃苏打饼干，并且一直在写和谈论她的经历。我们无法联系到伊丽莎白·芬奇做出回应。她的故事可能看起来非同寻常，但她并不是唯一一个做出虚假陈述的人。
In 2021, the website Intelligent.com surveyed more than 1200 white college applicants. More than a quarter of the respondents on the online survey said they had lied about being a racial minority on their college application. Blanca Véagoméz is the website's Higher Education Counselor. She says that most of the people who lied claimed to be Native American. And we found that the number one reason for why these applicants lied was they believe that they
2021年，网站Intelligent.com调查了1200多名白人大学申请者。在这项在线调查中，超过四分之一的受访者表示他们在大学申请中谎称自己是少数族裔。布兰卡·韦加戈梅斯是该网站的高等教育顾问。她说，大多数撒谎的人都声称自己是美洲原住民。我们发现这些申请者撒谎的头号原因是因为他们认为自己
would improve their chances of getting accepted. It used to be that we tried our best to conceal disadvantages, hardships and humiliations. Trauma's were often experienced as shameful and hidden away. In fact, in previous centuries, historians have documented numerous cases of people who were the target of discrimination, who did their best to avoid the labels that would invite prejudice. Many people of color try to pass as white to escape Jim Crow laws. Movies and plays document how women try to escape sexism and sexual violence by pretending to be men. As Jews fled the Holocaust, some pretended to be Gentiles.
会提高被录用的机会。过去，我们尽最大努力掩盖劣势、苦难和屈辱。创伤往往被视为不光彩的事情而被隐藏起来。事实上，在过去的几个世纪里，历史学家记录了大量遭受歧视的目标人群的案例，他们尽最大努力避开会招致偏见的标签。许多有色人种试图冒充白人以逃避吉姆·克劳法。电影和戏剧记录了女性如何通过假装成男性来逃避性别歧视和性暴力。当犹太人逃离大屠杀时，有些人假装是外邦人。
But new research explores a curious shift. Even as many people with limitations and disabilities continue to hide their challenges, others flaunt hardships that don't exist. This week on Hidden Brain, this train psychology of wanting to seem worse off than we really are. Why would you invent a disadvantage that doesn't exist? For a man by calling Arthur, who grew up in a small town outside Mexico City, the answer was clear. It was a way to avoid being the target of homophobic bullying. He vividly remembers a traumatic event during his freshman year of high school.
但一项新的研究探讨了一个奇怪的转变。甚至当许多有限制和残疾的人继续隐藏他们的挑战时，其他人却在炫耀并不存在的苦难。本周在Hidden Brain上，我们将探讨这种希望显得比实际更惨的心理学。为什么要捏造一个并不存在的劣势呢？对于一个名叫亚瑟的男子来说，他在墨西哥城郊区的一个小镇长大，答案很清楚。这是避免成为恐同欺凌目标的途径。他生动地记得高中一年级时发生的一次创伤性事件。
Students had gathered for a social event. We were supposed to be there just like to spend some time and to have fun and have his and bands and things. And then these guys kind of surrounded me. I think that they didn't try to, you know, like physically attack me, but because I was small and they were so big, I felt like, oh my God, these guys are gonna do something to me. Like bullies everywhere,
学生们聚集在一起参加一个社交活动。我们本该去那里消磨时间、寻找乐趣，还有乐队之类的东西。然后这些家伙把我包围了。我觉得他们并不是想，你知道的，从身体上攻击我，但因为我很小而他们那么大，我觉得，哦天哪，这些家伙会对做点什么。就像到处都有的霸凌者一样，
they knew exactly where to strike. And they were like, are you gay? I was like, no, no, no, no, no, no, like, and then they were like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, like. And then they were like, no, no, no, we know your gay. And then I was so scared. I was about to cry. And then my English teacher back then, she realized what was going on.
他们确切地知道该攻击哪里。他们问，你是同性恋吗？我当时说，不，不，不，不，不，不，像那样。然后他们说，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，像那样。然后他们说，不，不，不，我们知道你是同性恋。然后我吓坏了。我快要哭了。然后我当时的英语老师，她意识到了发生了什么。
And she got them away from me. That was the first time that I actually felt like they could physically harm me. So as Arthur went off to college, he decided to invent a story. He felt he could use it as a shield. Nice set. I need to create a character that is more appealing than who I actually am. Growing up, Arthur had watched his family work with Jewish business people, and he had always
她把他们从我身边拉开了。那是第一次我真正觉得他们会从身体上伤害我。因此，当亚瑟去上大学时，他决定编造一个故事。他觉得可以用它作为盾牌。不错。我需要创建一个比我真实的自我更有吸引力的角色。在成长过程中，亚瑟看着他的家人与犹太商人合作，他一直
admired the professional way of handling things. And so, the character that I created was like a Jewish descendant of my grandfather that was escaping the Spanish civil war. And so when people ask me like, hey, who are you? They're like, instead of saying like, yeah, I come from a small town in the middle of nowhere. Hi, it was like, no, yes, I come from, you know, like my family. I'm blah, blah, blah.
很欣赏他们处理事情的专业方式。因此，我创造的角色就像是我祖父的犹太后裔，逃离了西班牙内战。所以当人们问我，嘿，你是谁？他们说，与其说，是的，我来自偏远小镇。嗨，不如说，不，是的，我来自，你知道的，就像我的家庭。我是，巴拉巴拉巴拉。
And I felt so cool. The story gave Arthur a new identity. He wasn't a gay kid from small town Mexico. He was a glamorous grandson of Jewish refugees who had survived persecution in Europe. I think that it basically shielded me from homophobic bullying. I thought that if it ever came to that, that people would have a harder time discriminating me because I came from that background of persecution. But if I only said, yeah, I'm gay and it's a theorizing
我觉得太酷了。这个故事赋予了亚瑟一个新的身份。他不再是墨西哥小镇的同性恋小孩。他是欧洲大屠杀中幸存下来的犹太难民的光鲜亮丽的孙子。我认为这基本上让我免受了恐同欺凌。我以为如果真的到了那一步，人们歧视我会更加困难，因为我来自那个饱受迫害的背景。但如果我只说，是的，我是同性恋，这是一种理论
that I exposed me much more to that ugly side of bullying and discrimination. So I think that this narrative, like I come from that group that has already suffered that much, like kind of shielded me in a way. Can you say more about that? Because if you're suffering from one form of discrimination, it's not clear to me why identifying yourself with the second form of discrimination leaves you better off. It feels now you're pure setback in two different ways. Why did you feel it would make it would make a difference or did it actually make a difference? I think that it made a difference because homophobic discrimination in Mexico is
这让我更多地暴露在霸凌和歧视丑陋的一面。所以我觉得这种叙事，就像我来自那个已经遭受了那么多苦难的群体一样，在某种程度上保护了我。你能多谈谈这一点吗？因为如果你正在遭受一种形式的歧视，我并不清楚为什么把自己等同于第二种形式的歧视会让你的处境更好。感觉你现在在两个不同的方面都受到了纯粹的挫折。为什么你觉得这会有所不同，或者它真的有什么不同吗？我认为这有所不同，因为在墨西哥，恐同歧视比
much more tolerated than anti-semitism, for example. Openly discriminating at you is something that very few people would dare to do. But openly discriminating at gay person is something that happens on a daily basis everywhere. So I think that it left me better off. And even though I was playing the character of gay, Jew, man, I was still feeling more protected in that character than if I had been purely gay, for example.
反犹太主义更容易被容忍，例如。公开歧视你，是很少有人敢做的事。但公开歧视一个同性恋者是每天在各地都会发生的事。所以我觉得这让我的处境变得更好了。尽管我扮演着同性恋、犹太人、男人的角色，但在这个角色中，我仍然比单纯是同性恋时感到更加受到保护。
Now some people might challenge Arthur's beliefs about the extent of anti-Semitism in Mexico. But whether or not those beliefs were accurate, Arthur found his new backstory gave him confidence as he talked to friends. The long historical persecution of the Jews was now his story. People started to show him a certain deference. So I would be like, yes, they are listening to me. You know, I haven't survived and I'm being here and facing you and speaking with pride about my family history and all those things
现在有些人可能会挑战亚瑟关于墨西哥反犹太主义程度的信念。但无论这些信念是否准确，亚瑟发现他的新背景故事让他在与朋友交谈时获得了信心。犹太人悠久的历史迫害现在成了他的故事。人们开始对他表现出一种敬意。所以我会觉得，是的，他们在听我说话。你知道的，我没有死掉，我就在这里，面对着你，骄傲地谈论我的家族史和所有这些事情
like it made me brave in a way. Over time, the story morphed. Depending on the situation, Arthur would play up the victim in persecution angle. Other times, he would use his invented identity as a badge of expertise, playing on stereotypes that Jews were good at business. As he went through college, he found his story had fresh uses. Other people might have glamorous vacations and expensive habits, but his story of trauma and survival also had cachet.
这在某种程度上让我变得勇敢。随着时间的推移，这个故事发生了变化。根据情况的不同，亚瑟会夸大受害者和被迫害的角度。有时，他会利用自己捏造的身份作为专业知识的徽章，利用犹太人擅长经商的刻板印象。在大学期间，他发现他的故事有了新的用途。其他人可能会有光鲜的假期和昂贵的习惯，但他的创伤和生存故事也很有威望。
It was almost a form of currency. After he graduated, Arthur was working as an intern at the British Embassy. He was invited to a fancy end of your party. And that was the British residence, the house of the ambassador. And you can imagine like how gorgeous it was, like the long tables, the beautiful meal and everything. And so we were all invited there and I was so self-aware, I was like, oh my god, what am I gonna say? Around the dinner table. And I was sitting around with all the other interns and their expensive universities and they started talking about their trips and yeah my dad did this,
这几乎是一种货币形式。毕业后，亚瑟在英国大使馆做实习生。他被邀请参加一个盛大的年终派对。那是英国官邸，大使的房子。你可以想象它是多么华丽，长长的桌子，精美的饭菜和一切。所以我们都被邀请到那里，我感到非常不自然，我想，哦天哪，我该说些什么？在晚宴桌周围。我和其他实习生坐在一起，他们都来自昂贵的大学，他们开始谈论他们的旅行，是的，我爸爸做了这个，
my dad did that, my mom traveled there and I was just sitting at the table and was like, oh, I got what I'm going to say. And then eventually, it was my turn to say something. And then I was like, yeah, my dad is going to close that business. Because you know, we have a lot of connections like in the community. And they were like, what community? And I was like, the community. Like, did you wish community? like did you wish community. And then they were like, oh my god, I like it. Like, and then I was like, yes, I am.
我爸爸做了那个，我妈妈去那里旅游了，我只是坐在桌子旁，心想，哦，我知道我要说什么了。然后终于轮到我说点什么了。然后我说，是的，我爸爸要去谈妥那笔生意。因为你知道的，我们在社区里有很多联系。他们说，什么社区？我说，那个社区。就像，犹太社区吗？就像，犹太社区吗？然后他们说，哦天哪，我喜欢这样。然后我说，是的，我是。
And yeah, like in that situation, I felt like, oh my god, it's there. It worked, it worked. It was at another job after this internship that Arthur realized his invented story contained both benefits and risks. He found himself regularly clashing with a coworker. They had never gotten along well. On this day, they disagreed over an invoice. And I was like, what did you say? And in that moment, I think that she knew that she had already crossed the line.
是的，在这种情况下，我觉得，哦天哪，它就在那儿。成功了，成功了。正是在这次实习之后的另一份工作中，亚瑟意识到他捏造的故事既包含好处也包含风险。他发现自己经常与一位女同事发生冲突。他们从来没有好好相处过。在这一天，他们为一张发票发生了争执。我说，你刚才说什么？在那一刻，我想她知道自己已经越界了。
Arthur realized that his invented story of victimhood contained the risk of turning him into an actual victim. But he also saw how the incident gave him the power to undermine a coworker whom he disliked. I needed to accuse her. Yeah, yeah, like I needed to accuse her. Yeah, yeah, like like I needed to accuse her and I detailed my voice like you know what this happened. But then instead of wanting her fired, I think that I wanted to get away from the situation
亚瑟意识到，他编造的受害者故事包含着让自己变成真正受害者的风险。但他也看到了这一事件如何赋予他削弱他不喜欢的一位女同事的力量。我需要指责她。是的，是的，就像我需要指责她一样。是的，是的，就像我需要指责她一样，我详细说明了我的声音，你知道的，这发生了。但随后，我并没有想让她被解雇，我想我只是想摆脱这种处境
like it was just too harsh and I was just thinking like no let's leave it here. And at the same time mom I had already received my approval for studying in Australia. So I was like, enough, like this is the end. And so you left that position and you went to Australia? Did you keep the story alive there? No, no, and what happened? I thought that I was already cool like I was there like I didn't think that I need that character anymore In Australia Arthur didn't have to invent a story about how he was an outsider He was a gay foreign student from Mexico. He was obviously an outsider He no longer needed to be the descendant of persecuted Jews.
这实在是太严厉了，我当时想，不，让我们就此打住吧。与此同时，妈妈，我已经获得了去澳大利亚学习的批准。所以我当时想，够了，这就是终点。所以你离开了那个职位，去了澳大利亚？你在那里把这个故事继续下去了吗？不，不，发生了什么？我以为我已经很酷了，我在那里，我不觉得我还需要那个角色了。在澳大利亚，亚瑟不必编造一个关于自己如何成为局外人的故事。他是一个来自墨西哥的同性恋外国学生。他显然是个局外人。他不再需要成为受迫害的犹太人的后裔。
Yeah, yeah, that's what happened. That's what happened. And then I made a ton of friends over there, fellow Mexicans, and from all over the place where they're still in touch. And, yeah, exactly, that's exactly what happened. And yeah, exactly, that's exactly what happened. Arthur had discovered that his invented story of persecution gave him a number of advantages. On the surface, this is a paradox.
是的，是的，事情就是这样的。事情就是这样的。然后我在那边交了一大堆朋友，都是墨西哥同胞，还有来自世界各地的人，我们至今仍保持着联系。是的，没错，事情就是这样的。是的，没错，事情就是这样的。亚瑟发现，他虚构的被迫害故事给了他许多优势。表面上看，这是一个悖论。
Why would inventing hardships or trauma be an advantage? At a meeting of the Society for Personality and Social Psychology, I came by research that explained one dimension of this paradox. Psychologist Jillian Jordan at Harvard divided volunteers into two groups. She offered each slightly different scenarios about a college student named Sarah, who invites some friends over to her dorm room. One of her classmates, Gabrielle, asks to use her iPad to look something up and she agrees. And then eventually, Gabrielle and all the other classmates leave and Sarah relaxes at home and watches a TV show on her iPad and then she goes out. And in the neutral condition, that's the whole story.
为什么捏造苦难或创伤会是一种优势？在人格与社会心理学协会的一次会议上，我接触到了一项解释这一悖论某个维度的研究。哈佛大学的心理学家吉莉安·杰登将志愿者分为两组。她为每个人提供了关于一个名叫莎拉的女大学生的略有不同的情景，莎拉邀请了一些朋友到她的宿舍。她的一个同班同学加布里埃尔要求借用她的iPad查点东西，她同意了。最后，加布里埃尔和所有其他同学都离开了，莎拉在家里放松，在iPad上观看电视节目，然后她出去了。在中性情况下，这就是整个故事。
And in the victim condition, while she's out, we explain to participants that Gabrielle broke into her dorm room and stole her iPad. And so, you know, in both cases, she uses the iPad, she lends it to Gabrielle, she goes out, and then only in the victim condition does Gabrielle actually break in and steal her iPad. Note that in both conditions, Sarah's behavior is exactly the same. The only difference in the scenarios is that in one, she is a victim of theft. In the other, she is not. Julian asked volunteers whether they thought Sarah was a good person. Since Sarah's behavior in both scenarios was identical, there should be no difference in how she was perceived by people in the two groups.
而在受害者情况下，当她外出时，我们向参与者解释说，加布里埃尔闯入了她的宿舍并偷走了她的iPad。所以，你知道，在这两种情况下，她都使用了iPad，她把它借给加布里埃尔，她出去了，然后只有在受害者情况下，加布里埃尔才真正闯入并偷走了她的iPad。请注意，在这两种情况下，莎拉的行为完全相同。情景唯一的不同在于，在一个情景中，她是盗窃案的受害者。在另一个情景中，她不是。吉莉安问志愿者，他们是否认为莎拉是个好人。既然莎拉在这两种情况下的行为完全相同，那么两组人对她的看法应该没有区别。
But that is not what Julian found. When Sarah was a victim of theft, she is considered by participants to be a more moral and a more trustworthy person than the neutral condition. Jillian and her colleagues call this phenomenon the virtuous victim effect. So the virtuous victim effect is the finding that people tend to see victims of wrongdoing as more, more, more, good people than non-victims who have behaved identically. When we think about what it means to be a morally good person, we typically think about it means you've taken actions
但这并不是吉莉安所发现的。当莎拉是盗窃案的受害者时，参与者认为她比中性情况下的她更具道德感、更值得信赖。吉莉安和她的同事将这种现象称为“美德受害者效应”。因此，“美德受害者效应”是指人们倾向于将不当行为的受害者视为比行为相同的非受害者更善良、更好的人。当我们思考成为一个道德上好的人意味着什么时，我们通常会认为这意味着你采取了
that are morally good and you haven't taken actions that are morally bad, right? So I'm a morally good person. If I help others, I'm kind, I'm trustworthy, I'm not a morally good person. If I betray people, I spread nasty gossip, I'm never willing to help, I just think about myself. And in this case, people's moral character
道德上良好的行动，并且没有采取道德上糟糕的行动，对吧？所以我是个道德上好的人。如果我帮助别人，我很善良，我值得信赖；如果我背叛别人，散布恶毒的流言蜚语，从不愿帮忙，只想着自己，那我便不是一个道德上好的人。在这种情况下，人们的道德品质
is being influenced, not by actions they took. We talked about how those are constant across conditions in our experiments, but rather by the ways that they're treated by other people. And I think this seems sort of irrational in the sense that both good and bad people could be mistreated by somebody else. It doesn't really tell you something meaningful about my proclivity to behave morally, to learn that somebody else treated me badly. And yeah, the way that I'm treated by somebody else can influence perceptions of my moral
正在受到影响，不是因为他们采取了什么行动。我们讨论了这些在我们的实验中在各种情况下是如何保持不变的，而是受到其他人对待他们的方式的影响。我觉得这似乎有些不合理，因为好人和坏人都有可能受到别人的虐待。得知别人对我不好，并不能真正向你传达关于我倾向于道德行为的有意义的事情。是的，别人对待我的方式会影响人们对我的道德
character. else can influence perceptions of my moral character. Arthur intuitively grasped this when he came up with a story of family persecution. People seem to think he was a better person because his ancestors had suffered adversity. You can also see the same phenomenon on a larger scale. In many political disputes, two groups will each try to claim the moral high ground by talking about how they have been wronged. In these situations, people are not making up traumas,
品质的看法。别人对待我的方式会影响人们对我的道德品质的看法。当亚瑟编造家族被迫害的故事时，他直觉地抓住了这一点。人们似乎认为他是一个更好的人，因为他的祖先曾遭受过逆境。你也可以在更大的范围内看到同样的许多政治争端中，两个通过谈论自己如何受到冤枉来争夺道德制高点。在这些情况下，人们并没有捏造创伤，
but selectively focusing on traumas that show why they are deserving of sympathy. When the Israelis talk about how they are besieged by enemies who seek to destroy them, they are inviting us to see them as virtuous victims. When Palestinians focus on how they have been dispossessed by the Israelis, they are telling us that they are the virtuous victims. Gillian told me researchers were increasingly interested in studying such escalating wars for the moral high ground.
而是有选择地关注那些能够表明他们值得同情的创伤。当以色列人谈论他们如何被企图摧毁他们的敌人围困时，他们是在邀请我们视他们为美德受害者。当巴勒斯坦人关注他们如何被以色列人剥夺财产时，他们是在告诉我们他们才是美德受害者。吉莉安告诉我，研究人员对研究这种不断升级的争夺道德制高点的战争越来越感兴趣。
I should say there's also a lot of cool work around this concept of competitive victimhood when there's like a conflict between two groups and both sides wants to compete to like paint themselves as the rightful or larger victim. Sort of even without my research, like we can tell that first of all, if two groups are accusing the other side of being the perpetrator such that they're the victim, like you want to kind of compete to be the victim because that means by definition that the other side of being the perpetrator such that they're the victim, like you want to kind of compete to be the victim because that means by definition that the other side is bad. When we come back, three girls learn what it feels like to play the victim
我应该说，围绕竞争性受害者情结这个概念也有很多很酷的工作，当两个集团之间发生冲突时，双方都想争相把自己描绘成合法的或更大的受害者。即使没有我的研究，我们也可以看出，首先，如果两个集团都指责对方是加害者，而自己是受害者，就像你想争当受害者一样，因为这意味着根据定义，对方就是坏人。当我们回来时，三个女孩将了解扮演受害者的感觉，以及对驱动这种行为的人格特质的新研究。
and new research into the personality traits that drive such behavior. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Some time ago, a listener called in with an unusual story. We'll call her Paula. She told us that when she was in high school many years ago, she got close to two other students. We'll call them Sarah and Jessica. We're using pseudonyms at the request of the women. By the time Jessica, Sarah and Paula were in 10th grade, they were all considered high achievers.
你正在收听的是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。不久前，一位听众打来电话，讲述了一个不寻常的故事。我们叫她保拉。她告诉我们，许多年前她上高中时，她和另外两个学生走得很近。我们叫她们莎拉和杰西卡。应这些女性的要求，我们使用了化名。到了杰西卡、莎拉和保拉上十年级的时候，她们都被认为是优等生。
Paula was the athlete. I was definitely the jock in my school. If there was ever anything sport-related, I was on the team. I was likely captain and VP. That's just kind of the reputation I had carved out for myself. Jessica was a social activist. She was very invested in helping the environment. So she actually started her own environmental youth group. And Sarah was a star who made Stardom look effortless. She was very good at procrastinating, doing everything super last minute, but ended up becoming straight-A student, was on all these committees, and was beloved by everyone in our school.
保拉是运动员。我绝对是我学校里的运动健将。如果有什么与体育相关的事情，我都在队里。我经常担任队长和副队长。这正是我为自己打造的声誉。杰西卡是一名社会活动家。她非常热心于帮助环境。所以她实际上创办了自己的环境青年组织。莎拉则是一个让成名看起来毫不费力的明星。她非常擅长拖延，把所有事情都留到最后一分钟，但最终却成了一名全A学生，加入了所有这些委员会，并且深受我们学校每个人的喜爱。
Sarah was also a Thessbian, and acted in local community theatre. Paula told me that the three friends felt like they were headed somewhere. They had talent, and they had drive. One summer, when the girls were 16, they went on vacation together. It was their first time traveling without their parents. They spent four days in a new city visiting museums, eating at restaurants and touring local colleges. For their last adventure, they went to a popular amusement park. When we got there, it looked really grand, so there's just people everywhere. It was probably the most people I've ever seen in one place. The lines for all the rides were over two hours to get to the main rides, and so we're
莎拉也是个女同性恋，并在当地社区剧院演戏。保拉告诉我，这三个朋友觉得她们前途无量。她们有才华，也有干劲。有一年夏天，当女孩们16岁时，她们一起去度假。这是她们第一次在没有父母陪伴的情况下旅行。她们在一个新城市度过了四天，参观博物馆，在餐馆吃饭，并参观当地的大学。作为她们的最后一次冒险，她们去了一个受欢迎的游乐园。当我们到达那里时，它看起来非常宏伟，到处都是人。这可能是我见过的最多人聚集在一个地方的一次。所有游乐设施的排队时间都超过了两个小时才能玩到主要的游乐设施，所以我们
definitely a bit overwhelmed and feeling like we weren't going to be able to see all the things that we wanted to see on this trip. The girls had done some research beforehand to figure out what rides the park offered. As the day grew hotter, they set their hearts on some water rides. It's a little bit more fun, not the drop type rides. I don't really like those, but I like the ones that kind of go on an adventure. And there was like water features with them. So that's why they were such a draw on this day because it was so hot.
确实感到有点不知所措，觉得我们这次旅行可能无法看到所有想看的东西。女孩们事先做了一些研究，了解公园提供哪些游乐设施。随着天气越来越热，她们看中了几个水上项目。那种项目稍微更有趣一点，不是那种垂直下落的过山车。我其实不太喜欢那种，但我喜欢那种有点像去探险的。而且它们还带有水景。所以这就是它们在今天这么热的天气里如此吸引人的原因。
Everybody was wanting to go on the rides where you kind of like splashed into water. They got in line for their first ride. It really was two hours long. And as they waited and waited, and it got hotter and hotter, their moods plummeted. If this is what they had to look forward to the rest of the day,
每个人都想去那种会溅起水花的游乐项目。她们排队准备玩第一个项目。队伍真的排了足足两个小时。随着她们等啊等，天气越来越热，她们的情绪也低落到了谷底。如果这就是她们接下来一整天都要面对的景象，
they were going to be miserable. They forward to the rest of the day, they were going to be miserable. They could see the lines for the other rides were also really long. It didn't feel worth it, I guess, to have gone all the way, to have gone our way all the way to this park. We were really excited for the day, and so I think we were a bit kind of between frustrated and disappointed as well, because we're kind of waiting in line for this long time like we enjoy each other's company, but we also really wanted to experience everything there. So I think we were like the combination of frustrated, disappointed and a little desperate. The three girls looked at each other. They were driven, they were smart, and they wanted to find a way to skip the long lines.
她们可就要倒大霉了。她们（重复：接下来一整天，她们可就要倒大霉了。）她们看到其他项目的队伍也长的离谱。我想，大老远跑来这个公园，结果却是这样，真觉得不值得。我们本来对这一天充满了期待，所以我觉得我们当时处于一种既沮丧又失望的状态，因为我们在长长的队伍里等了这么久，虽然我们很享受彼此陪伴的时光，但我们也真的非常渴望能在那里体验到所有东西。所以我觉得我们当时的心情是沮丧、失望和一点绝望的结合体。三个女孩对视了一眼。她们很有冲劲，很聪明，而且她们想找个办法插队。
So we were kind of brainstorming ways to kind of get around this dilemma, this problem that was in front of us. And so we were kind of came up with the idea of like, okay, well, what type of people don't have to stand in line. And we were like, okay, people who work work here potentially maybe they get like a special pass or you have to like pay more money and then we saw somebody kind of literally roll up in a wheelchair up the exit and if you go up the exit you just skipped the front of the line and we just kind of looked at each other and were like, maybe there's something there.
所以我们当时就在集思广益，想办法绕过这个困境，也就是摆在我们面前的这个难题。于是我们想出了一个主意，比如，好吧，什么样的人不用排队呢？然后我们想，好吧，在这里工作的人可能潜在地会拿到某种特别通行证，或者你必须花更多钱。接着我们看到有人居然直接坐着轮椅从出口上去了，如果你从出口上去，就可以直接跳过队头，我们互相看了一眼，觉得这其中可能大有文章。
One of them throughout the idea, to create a character with a disability who could get them to the front of the lines. Sarah, the actress, volunteered to take on the role. She was actually seemed excited by the idea that she could use her acting skills. And so the rest of us kind of came up with the story behind what was happening. And so myself and Jessica were family members. And so I looked a little bit more like Sarah. And so I was going to be Sarah's cousin and Jessica was going to be my friend.
其中一个人提出了一个主意：创造一个有残疾的角色，让他们能够直接走到队伍前面。作为演员的莎拉自告奋勇地承担了这个角色。她似乎对这个可以通过演技发挥的主意感到很兴奋。于是我们其他人开始编造事情背后的故事。我和杰西卡扮演家庭成员。我长得跟莎拉稍微更像一点，所以我要当莎拉的表姐，而杰西卡则是我的朋友。
The girls knew they couldn't fake a physical disability, so they decided to have Sarah fake a neurological disability. Sarah, I think if I were to think about the type of disability it is, I would say that she was kind of on the nonverbal autism spectrum would have been kind of the performance, I guess. And so she was acting agitated from the heat. There was noise, the whole performance. I mean, she crushed it. Paula, Jessica, and the new Sarah activated the next phase of their plan.
女孩们知道她们无法假装身体残疾，所以她们决定让莎拉假装患有神经系统方面的残疾。莎拉，如果要我想象这是什么类型的残疾的话，我会说她当时的表演有点像是处于非言语自闭症谱系上。当时她因为炎热而显得有些情绪激动。有噪音，还有整套表演。我的意思是，她演得太棒了。宝拉、杰西卡和全新的莎拉开始执行她们计划的下一步。
And we had her sitting off to the side, and then I went up to the booth, and I kind of explained and asked questions, like, do you have any passes or anything that we can do for my cousin, and she was on the bench visible kind of behaving in a way that made it a little bit more believable and we had a towel over her head and we like put water on it because we were trying like cool her down and she was like grunting and groaning and and flailing her arms and and everything while she was sitting and kind of like hitting Jessica a little bit. So it was like a full, full like auditory and visual performance. Despite Sarah's acting, the people at the ticketing booth said no to the request for special passes.
我们让她坐在旁边，然后我走到售票亭，解释并询问了一些问题，比如你们有没有什么通行证或者我们可以为我表姐做点什么。而她当时坐在长椅上，表现得清晰可见，行为举止让人觉得稍微更可信一些。我们在她头上盖了一条毛巾，还往上面泼水，因为我们试图帮她降温。她坐在那里发出哼哼唧唧的声音，挥舞着手臂，甚至还稍微打了打杰西卡。所以这是一场全方位的、视听结合的表演。尽管莎拉的演技很逼真，但售票亭的工作人员拒绝了她们索要特殊通行证的请求。
It's possible, of course, that they had encountered other people who I tried to game the system. I could tell that the workers there, they seem like now when I think back, they were definitely like our age. They would have been teenagers as well, but they were definitely skeptical. And so they said no, and so then I went over to my friend and we kind of talked a little bit and kind of came up with a game plan that that Sarah and Jessica would come over with me to make it a little bit more believable. The three girls ramped up the pressure on the teenagers in the ticketing booth. Sarah continued to act disabled and distressed. She just was consistent. She was very good at kind of keeping this whole
当然，这也有可能是因为他们以前遇到过其他试图钻空子的人。我看得出来，那里的工作人员，现在回想起来，他们绝对和我们年纪相仿。他们应该也是青少年，但他们绝对持怀疑态度。所以他们拒绝了，然后我走到我朋友那边，我们商量了一下，制定了一个游戏计划，让莎拉和杰西卡跟我一起过来，这样能让事情显得更真实一些。三个女孩向售票亭的青少年施加了更多压力。莎拉继续假装残疾和痛苦。她始终如一。她非常擅长保持这种整体状态
very good at kind of keeping this whole Shred up the whole time she seemed agitated and hot and after a little bit I had her and Jessica go back and sit down again and a big chunk of it was us kind of going off and me fake consoling her and sitting on the bench with her. I think we were trying to make it seem a little bit more believable by not going anywhere and giving up. And I kind of continued to negotiate with the workers. The workers pointed out that passes were meant for people who could not physically stand in line. Sarah could stand. She didn't need a wheelchair.
非常擅长在整个过程中一直维持这种伪装。她看起来情绪激动且酷热难耐。过了一会儿，我让卡和杰西卡回去坐下，很大一部分原因是我们在演戏，我假装在安慰她，和她一起坐在长椅上。我想我们试图通过不离开、不放弃来让事情显得更真实一些。我继续和工作人员进行交涉。工作人员指出，通行证是为那些身体无法站着排队的人准备的。莎拉可以站立。她不需要轮椅。
We really kind of had to position our argument that waiting in line in the heat was going to make her disruptive. I believe they ended up having to get a supervisor come give us the pass. I think it probably took us about 20 or 30 minutes, the whole ordeal. So 20 or 30 minutes, I mean, that is, that is, I thought you were going to say two or three minutes. So 20 or 30 minutes is like, I mean, that is like, that's a lot. Yeah. We were very dedicated and committed individuals. We kind of had like a goal in mind. We were very tunnel vision, tunnel focused on kind of getting
我们真的不得不这样组织我们的论点：在炎热的天气里排队会使她的病情发作，变得具有破坏性。我相信他们最终不得不叫来一个主管给我们办通行证。整个过程大概花了二十到三十分钟。所以，二十到三十分钟，我的意思是，这，这，我以为你会说两三分钟。所以二十到三十分钟，这就意味着，这真的很长。是的。我们是非常有奉献精神和坚定决心的人。我们脑子里有个目标。我们的视野非常狭窄，全神贯注于如何达成
what we wanted out of the situation. The first thing they did after the supervisor interceded to give them the passes was to head over to the entrance to a water right. They went right past a gigantic, snaking line of hot, agitated people. And instead of standing in line at the start, we just walk in the exit so where all the people come out after they finish the ride, show them our pass, they just opened it up and we got first crack at sitting wherever we wanted and it was amazing. We just did the same water ride like three times in a row. We were thinking we were so smart, we were so
我们在这种情况下想要的东西。在主管出面发给她们通行证后，她们做的第一件事就是直奔一个水上游乐设施的入口。她们直接走过了一条由焦虑、烦躁的人群组成的长得像蛇一样的巨大队伍。我们没有在队伍起点排队，而是直接从出口走进去，也就是人们玩完项目后出来的那个地方，向他们出示我们的通行证，他们直接把门打开了，我们获得了优先挑选座位的机会，想坐哪就坐哪，这太棒了。我们连续三次玩了同一个水上游乐项目。我们觉得自己太聪明了，我们
elated, so excited, was to stick to it. Sarah couldn't step out of character. I found it so entertaining that my friend had to stay in character, and she stayed in character on the ride. So we're going through these drops and turns and everything like that. And she's fully expressing in this character the entire time. And so she would bring her arms forward and sort of flutter and flail them, like kind of cheering and the elation and giggling and laughing.
欣喜若狂，兴奋不已，那就是坚持到底。莎拉不能出戏。我觉得我朋友必须保持角色状态这件事太有趣了，而且她在玩项目的时候也一直保持着角色状态。所以我们在经历这些下坠和转弯以及各种各样的事情时。她全程都在完全展现这个角色的状态。所以她会把胳膊向前伸，然后像拍打翅膀一样挥舞它们，仿佛在欢呼、欣喜若狂、咯咯傻笑。
She was definitely like having like repetitive movements of joy. Like that's the part that if you have like a that flash bulb or that photographic kind of memory, like the thing that's imprinted on my brain is like watching her perform joy while on the rides and like the overtone or the feeling that we were having at the time was like we outsmarted somebody. The three girls stayed in the amusement park for several hours and went on every ride they wanted. Paula
她绝对表现出了喜悦的重复性动作。如果你有那种闪光灯般或照片般的记忆，这就是那部分，烙印在我脑海里的东西就是看着她在游乐设施上表现出喜悦，而当时我们的基调或感觉就是我们智胜了某人。这三个女孩在游乐园里待了好几个小时，玩了她们想玩的所有项目。宝拉
estimates they were able to go on 15 different rides, some of them multiple times. Without the passes, they might have made it to two or three. On the way home, Paula, Jessica and Sarah had a talk. They agreed not to tell anyone else about what they had done. In fact, they came up with a story of how tough the day had been. Yeah, we had a story that the lines were really long, we only went on a few rides. It was really fun, but we're really tired, that kind of thing. So we did kind of have a a chat about a story to make sure that we were all kind of on the same page.
估计她们玩了15个不同的项目，其中有些项目还玩了好几次。如果没有通行证，她们可能只能玩两三个。在回家的路上，宝拉、杰西卡和莎拉进行了一次交谈。她们一致同意不把她们做过的事告诉其他人。事实上，她们编造了一个关于那天有多艰难的故事。是的，我们编了个故事，说队伍太长了，我们只玩了几个项目。虽然很好玩，但真的很累，诸如此类的话。所以我们确实就一个故事进行了交谈，以确保我们所有人的说法都完全一致。
It was only after a while that they started to rethink their actions. I think once we were coming home, it started to kind of really sink in what like the gravity of the situation and how it's not really in line with who we are as people or who we want to be as people or how we see ourselves rather. And so it did take a while for it to fully sink in. I think it was definitely like once we were back home we started thinking that we had done something shameful. As an adult, Paula has sometimes thought back to those teenagers in the ticketing booth who were suspicious of Sarah's performance.
过了一段时间，她们才开始重新审视自己的行为。我想一旦我们在回家的路上，事情的严重性就开始真正深入人心了，这与我们作为人的本质，或者我们希望成为什么样的人，或者相反，我们如何看待自己并不相符。所以这确实花了一段时间才完全沉淀下来。我想绝对是等我们回到家后，我们才开始觉得我们做了一件可耻的事。成年后，宝拉有时会回想起售票亭里那些对莎拉的表演起疑心的青少年。
She realizes that they gave in not because they were convinced by her story, but because they felt silenced by it. I don't know if they actually believed us us or if it was just so uncomfortable to call somebody out for faking something like that because imagine if we weren't faking it, how horrible that would be for an employee to say you're faking it. So I think we probably put them in a really uncomfortable position and so they ended up just agreeing. When we come back, the personality traits of people who cry wolf.
她意识到，他们妥协不是因为被她的故事说服了，而是因为他们觉得自己被故事剥夺了说话的权力。我不知道他们是否真的相信我们，还是因为指出某人在假装这种事让人感到太尴尬了，因为想象一下，如果我们不是在装病，一个员工对你说你在装病，那该有多糟糕。所以我认为我们可能把他们置于一个非常尴尬的境地，所以他们最终只能选择同意。稍后回来，狼来了的人的人格特质。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When Kala Kena was six years old, all the kids at school were asked to share what they ate for breakfast. So I remember saying that what I had was a dish made out of pigs feet and banana blossoms. And that generated quite a bit of laughter from the other classmates. Kals family had recently immigrated to the United States from the Philippines. They're imprinted in my memory, and it's been hard to fully forget about. I mean, they don't have the same, obviously, the same sting now or anything like that. I look at them more as a kind of curiosity in a way of thinking about what might be experience be like for other people.
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。卡拉·凯娜六岁时，学校里所有的孩子都被要求分享他们早餐吃什么。我记得我说我吃的是一道用猪脚和香蕉花做成的菜。这引起了其他同学的一阵笑话。卡尔的家人最近从菲律宾移民到美国。这些记忆深深印在我的脑海里，而且很难彻底忘掉。我的意思是，它们显然没有那种同样的刺痛感了，或者诸如此类的事情。我更多地把它们看作是一种好奇心，一种去思考别人的经历可能会是什么样的途径。
Much has changed in the US in the years since Carl immigrated here. Many schools now go out of their way to welcome students of diverse backgrounds and to embrace cultural differences. Anti-bullying programs are widespread. As a culture, while we're still far from perfect, we've gotten better at caring for the disadvantaged. People who experience hardships are encouraged to ask for help. Carl eventually became a psychologist. He started to notice how regularly students came to him with accounts of various limitations.
自从卡尔移民到这里以来，美国的许多事情都发生了变化。如今，许多学校不遗余力地欢迎具有不同背景的学生，并包容文化差异。反霸凌项目十分普遍。作为一种文化，虽然我们离完美还很远，但我们在照顾弱势群体方面已经做得越来越好了。经历过艰难困苦的人被鼓励寻求帮助。卡尔最终成为了一名心理学家。他开始注意到学生们带着各种局限性的诉求来找他的频率有多高。
I will get requests from students for accommodations for certain things because they're experiencing anxiety or depression or some other kind of psychological challenge. Karl was usually sympathetic, but he was also struck by how times had changed from when he was a student. I remember when I was younger, I would also be
我会收到学生的要求，希望对某些事情提供便利，因为他们正在经历焦虑、抑郁或其他某种心理挑战。卡尔通常很同情他们，但也对时代与他作为学生时相比发生了怎样的变化感到震惊。我记得自我年轻的时候，我也经常
beset by by these anxieties. I would worry about tests and I just didn't didn't go to my teacher and talk about it. So really that that was for me a bit of an eye opener that there's an increasing willingness to accommodate or be responsive to different claims that a student might make about hardship or challenge in life. I think it's actually a reflection of the fact that human beings appear to be increasingly concerned about alleviating each other's suffering. Partly as a result of these experiences and his own childhood experiences of feeling
受到这些焦虑的困扰。我会担心考试，但我就是没有去找老师谈论这事。所以对我来说，这确实有点大开眼界，人们越来越愿意去适应或回应学生可能对生活中艰难或挑战提出的不同诉求。我认为这实际上反映了这样一种事实：人类似乎越来越关心如何减轻彼此的痛苦。部分由于这些经历以及他自己童年时感到
like an outsider, Carl got curious about the ways people ask for help. He wrote an article about this idea. It's a very simple idea. You know, people want to help. How do they know that you need help? Well, you have to tell them somehow, all right? By signaling that one is a victim, one is able to potentially get others, I'll call them bed of factors to provide that person with resources.
像个局外人的经历，卡尔对人们寻求帮助的方式产生了好奇。他写了一篇关于这个想法的文章。这是一个非常简单的想法。你知道，人们想要帮忙。他们怎么知道你需要帮助呢？好吧，你必须通过某种方式告诉他们，对吧？通过发出自己是受害者的信号，人们能够潜在地让其他人——我称之为资助者——为这个人提供资源。
Carl hypothesized that people who signal that their legitimate victims of harm would indeed attract help, especially if they also communicated that their legitimate victims of harm would indeed attract help, especially if they also communicated that they were worthy of help. If you want to maximize the effectiveness of this signal of your need, it helps to combine it with being virtuous, because it makes people more willing to help us. You're going more likely to help someone who you think has virtue than someone who you think is, you know, a moral reprobator to generate, right? I mean, nobody wants to help that other person.
卡尔假设，那些发出自己是真正受害者的信号的人确实会吸引帮助，特别是当他们同时传达出自己值得帮助的信息时。如果你想最大化这种对你需求信号的效力，最好把它与美德结合起来，因为这会让人更愿意帮助我们。你更有可能去帮助一个你认为有美德的人，而不是一个你认为道德败坏的人，对吧？我的意思是，没有人愿意去帮助那种人。
And so it's very obvious that the maximal effectiveness of any kind of signal of need is to combine need being a victim with virtue. That's the basic idea. That's the basic idea. At this point, Karl was not thinking about people who fake hardships. He was just hypothesizing that virtuous victims were more likely to elicit help. As a way to empirically test his hypotheses, Karl devised a scale to identify people who tell others about their challenges and traumas. The scale enrolled a number of questions. And we ended up with a set of 10 items, 10 questions that reflect different ways that
因此，很明显，任何形式的求助信号的最大效用，是将“身为受害者”的需求与“美德”结合起来。这就是基本的主旨。这就是基本的主旨。在当时，卡尔并没有去想那些伪造苦难的人。他只是在假设，具有美德的受害者更有可能唤起人们的帮助。为了通过实证检验他的假设，卡尔设计了一个量表，用来识别那些向他人讲述自己挑战和创伤的人。该量表包含了一系列问题。最终，我们得到了由10个项目组成的集合，即10个问题，反映了各种不同的方式
people might signal their hardship or disadvantage. I'll just read you a few here. Discussed how my concerns and needs are not being heard by political leaders. Shared how I don't feel comfortable with my body. Discussed how I don't feel financially secure. Told others that I get paid less based on my identity. Explained how I don't feel accepted
人们可能会以此来暗示他们的苦难或弱势。我在这里只读几个给你们听。讨论我的关切和需求如何未被政治领导人倾听。分享我对自己的身体感到很不自在。讨论我如何觉得自己在经济上没有安全感。告诉别人我因为自己的身份而获得较低的报酬。解释我如何因为自己的身份而感到不被
in the society because of my identity. I spoke about how people who share my identity are criminalized by society, expressed how people like me are underrepresented in the media and leadership, made it known that I can't move freely within or outside of my country. Once he had this questionnaire in hand, Kyle was able to identify people who answered yes to one or more of these questions. He now started to look for clues about the motivations and traits of these people.
在这个社会中被接纳。我谈到了那些与我共享相同身份的人是如何被社会刑事定罪的，表达了像我这样的人如何在媒体和领导层中代表性不足，并让人知道我无法在我的国家内部或外部自由移动。一旦有了这份问卷，凯尔就能够识别出对其中一个或多个问题回答“是”的人。现在，他开始寻找关于这些人的动机和特征的线索。
Okay, so the next part was to see whether there are certain personality characteristics that might predict whether a person is likely to signal victimhood. And I just started playing around with the data. It's really just, um, happenstance. I, um, I was trying to validate the scale in a sample, larger sample, um, of students, and included in that data collection effort, where other scales that my colleagues had thrown in.
好的，所以接下来的部分是看是否存在某些人格特征，能够预测一个人是否更有可能发出受害者身份的信号。我只是开始摆弄这些数据。这真的只是，嗯，机缘巧合。我，嗯，我当时正试图在学生样本（一个更大的样本）中验证这个量表，而该数据收集工作中所包含的内容，还有我的同事们加入的其他量表。
Carl looked to see if the people who self-identified themselves as victims were also likely to show up on other scales and measures. To his surprise, he found a connection with another scale that measured something completely different. And all I did is I just, I mean, I basically looked at the correlation. It's just a very simple analysis out of curiosity. And I found out that the scale that we were developing was correlated with another scale,
卡尔观察那些自我认同为受害者的人是否也更有可能在其他量表和测量中显现出来。令他惊讶的是，他发现这与另一个测量完全不同事物的量表存在某种联系。而我所做的全部事情，就是，我的意思是，我基本上看了看相关性。这只是一个出于好奇的非常简单的分析。我发现我们正在开发的量表与另一个量表相关，
which measures what's called the dark triad of personality. The so-called dark triad consists of three personality traits you've probably heard about. None of them is very nice. Machiavellianism, basically, whether you're willing to immorally manipulate others to get what you want. Narcissism, probably most people know, but that's sort of a grandiose belief about yourself. You think you're superior to others. And then, subclinical psychopathy, which is not the psychopathy that you associate with a serial killer,
该量表测量的是所谓的“暗黑人格三联征”。所谓的三联征包含你可能听说过的人格特征。它们没有一个看起来是很好的。马基雅维利主义，基本上是指你是否愿意为了得到你想要的东西而不道德地操纵他人。自恋，大概大多数人都知道，这是一种对自己的宏大看法。你认为自己比别人优越。然后是亚临床精神病态，这并不是你与连环杀手联系在一起的那种精神病态，
but really more of a kind of, I would call it emotional shalonist or lack of remorse when you do bad things. And that was just, I had no idea that would happen to solve the correlation. And there it was, it popped out and I started thinking, hmm, that's curious. It popped out and I started thinking, hmm, that's curious. What might that show? And it struck me that I wonder if people who are high in these traits are more likely to use these signals for personal gain. Karl had found a correlation, but that does not imply causation. So he and his colleagues ran a number
而更像是某种，我称之为情感沙文主义的东西，或者在做坏事时缺乏悔意。当时我根本不知道会有这种相关性。结果它就这么出现了，我开始心想，嗯，这真奇妙。它就这么出现了，我开始心想，嗯，这真奇妙。这可能说明了什么？这让我突然想到，我很想知道那些在这些特征上得分较高的人是否更有可能利用这些信号来谋取个人利益。卡尔发现了相关性，但这并不意味着因果关系。因此，他和他的同事们进行了多项
of experiments to test if there was a real connection. We know from the literature on the dark personality that they are more likely to do things like lie or cheat to try to get what they want. And that's the third part of the paper was to show that the dark personality does predict was to show that the dark personality does predict a willingness to signal victimhood and virtue. In one of his experiments, call examined whether people were willing to paint a coworker in a bad light in order to make themselves look better.
实验来检验是否存在真正的联系。我们从有关黑暗人格的文献中得知，他们更有可能做出诸如撒谎或作弊之类的事情，以试图得到他们想要的东西。论文的第三部分就是要证明，黑暗人格确实能够预测，是要证明黑暗人格确实能够预测一个人发出受害者和美德信号的意愿。在他的其中一个实验中，卡尔检验了人们是否愿意把同事描绘成不好的人，以便让自己看起来更好。
So in this task, we had people imagine that they were working together with another intern and there was a kind of competitive situation they're competing for a job. After giving the volunteers a description of what the other intern had done, the volunteers were given an opportunity to offer a performance evaluation of the other person. They could stick to the facts or falsely say the intern had behaved poorly. Then we gave descriptions of things that that intern might have done, such as they don't
所以在这次任务中，我们让人们想象他们正在和另一个实习生一起工作，并且存在一种竞争情境，他们在竞争一份工作。在向志愿者描述了另一个实习生所做的事情之后，志愿者获得了一个机会，可以对另一个人的表现进行评价。他们可以坚持事实，或者虚假地说这个实习生表现糟糕。然后我们给出了这个实习生可能做过的事情的描述，例如他们不
respect your suggestions. You think they might be saying things behind your back. We found that people who were higher in the virtuous victim signaling scales were more willing to report these behaviors that didn't infert, in fact, stated as having occurred. These fictitious behaviors, another one. This is just behavior, yeah. And we reason that because, you know, that you put them in this kind of competitive situation,
尊重你的建议。你认为他们可能在背后说你的坏话。我们发现，在美德受害者信号量表上得分更高的人，更愿意报告那些实际上并没有发生的不当行为。这些虚构的行为，又是另一个。这只是行为，是的。我们推断，因为，你知道，你把他们置于这种竞争情境中，
that it's to their benefit to cast their rival in a less positive light. I want to stop here to underline something very important. Carl is not saying that everyone who talks about their hardships and limitations is a manipulator and narcissist. Indeed many, perhaps most of the people who tell you they are experiencing limitations, are doing so sincerely. But what Karl is saying is that some subset of the people who claim to be victims are
把竞争对手描绘得不那么积极，是对他们有利的。我想在这里停一下，以强调一件非常重要的事情。卡尔并不是说所有谈论自己苦难和局限的人都是操纵者和自恋者。事实上，许多、也许大多数告诉你他们正在经历局限的人，都是真诚的。但卡尔所说的是，自称是受害者的这群人中的某个子集
likely pretenders, and these pretenders may be motivated by a desire to manipulate the empathy of potential benefactors. It's just another reminder that there are going to be times when one might be moved by sentiments to help another person. And that person might not be the kind of person you'd want to help because they might exploit you. So, call these behaviors are intersecting at this moment in our cultural life with the fact that we are living in a society that is increasingly interested, or at least many people say they are increasingly interested,
很可能是伪装者，而这些伪装者可能是出于操纵潜在恩人同理心的愿望。这只是另一个提醒，有时人们可能会被情感所触动去帮助另一个人。而那个人可能并不是你想帮助的那种人，因为他们可能会剥削你。所以，称这些行为在我们的文化生活中的这个时刻相互交织，事实上我们生活在一个日益关注，或者至少许多人说他们日益关注的社会中，
in being an acting compassionate. So in other words, there's a supply of compassion as well as a demand for it. And in some ways what your paper is talking about is the intersection of these two worlds where there's a supply of compassion. There are people who genuinely are in need of compassion, but there are also people who are saying, given that there's a supply of compassion, how can I get some of it, even if I don't deserve it? Yeah, that's a very good analysis. If you look at it in terms of a market, you want to reach the equilibrium where you're actually, you're legitimately allocating resources to people in need. As opposed to allocating resources to people who don't really need it, but are being able
表现并付诸同情。换句话说，既有同情的供给，也有同期的需求。在某种程度上，你的论文所讨论的是这两个世界的交集，这里存在同情的供给。有些人确实需要同情，但也有人会说，既然有同情的供给，我怎么能从中分一杯羹，即使我不配拥有它？是的，这是一个很好的分析。如果你从市场的角度来看，你会希望达到这样一个平衡点，即你实际上是在将资源合乎逻辑地分配给真正需要的人。而不是将资源分配给那些并不真正需要它，却能够
to exploit this what you call surplus of compassion. One of the inspirations for the paper was I read an article in a Canadian newspaper about a woman who posted on, go find me that she had cancer. Family and friends rallied around the woman in a raffle was held to collect money, but police are now alleging the entire campaign was a scam and she didn't really have cancer. But I think you know when people are because people are very motivated to try to alleviate suffering, it can be sometimes easy for those who might have the dark-tried personality, let's say,
利用这种你所谓的同情顺差的人。这篇论文的灵感来源之一是，我在一份加拿大报纸上读到一篇文章，讲的是一个女人在众筹网站GoFundMe上发帖称自己得了癌症。家人和朋友围绕着这个女人给予支持，并举行了一场抽奖活动来筹集资金，但警方现在指控整个活动是一场骗局，她根本没有得癌症。但我认为你知道，由于人们非常渴望试图减轻苦难，有时对于那些可能拥有黑暗人格特质的人来说，
to use that for their own benefit. Do you even want to extremes to shave her head and cut her skin and call them cancer bumps? Take time off work for these fake surgeries that didn't actually happen. So it was kind of extreme measure. If I see a GoFundMe page of someone who basically says they have cancer, and I want to help them, but it turns out that they're merely exploiting me, that in some ways prevents me from actually helping the person who actually needs help.
利用这一点来为自己谋利会变得很容易。你甚至会走向极端，剃光头、在皮肤上割伤口并称它们为癌症疙瘩？为这些实际上并未发生的虚假手术请假。所以这是一种极端措施。如果我看到某个自称得了癌症的人的GoFundMe页面，并且我想帮助他们，但结果证明他们只是在剥削我，这在某种程度上阻碍了我真正去帮助那个真正需要帮助的人。
The person who actually has cancer and might not have the resources to deal with it. Exactly. So it's about a, you're diverting resources, attention, concern, away from people in legitimate need, to those who might be feigning whatever experience they're claiming they have. And again, we can say nothing in this paper about whether these people are not legitimately experiencing these things, but the inference that you're drawing is certainly, I think, one of the implications. Now, there's sort of a flip side of this, which is, let's say, for example, now I'm alerted
那个真正得了癌症并且可能没有资源去应对的人。完全正确。所以，这是关于，你将资源、关注、关切，从真正有需要的人身上转移开，转移到那些可能在伪装他们声称自己拥有的任何经历的人身上。同样，我们在这篇论文中不能说明这些人是否没有合法地经历这些事情，但你得出的推论当然我认为是其中的含义之一。现在，这里有一种类似硬币另一面的情况，也就是说，比方说，现在我被警示了
to the fact that there are some unscrupulous people, or perhaps people who have, you know, dark personality traits, who are likely, or who are more likely to set up a GoFundMe page saying that they have cancer. And so now I have my skepticism up. I have my radar up to try and spot these cases. But of course, the truth is I can't really look at a GoFundMe page and tell very much about whether this is the legitimate case or not. Is it possible that this can inadvertently reduce
注意到有这样一些不道德的人，或者可能具有黑暗人格特质的人，他们很有可能，或者更有可能建立一个GoFundMe页面，声称他们得了癌症。所以现在我提高了怀疑度。我提高了雷达警惕来试图发现这些案例。但当然，事实是我并不能真正看着一个GoFundMe页面，就能辨别出这到底是不是一个真实的案例。这是否有可能无意中减少
my compassion overall? Because now I'm actually saying I'm skeptical of the people who are coming to me for help, because I'm aware that some portion of them might be counterfeit, or some portion of them might be pretenders. Is there a risk in some ways that this can, in some ways, reduce the supply of compassion in general?
我整体的同情心？因为现在我实际上是在说，我对那些向我寻求帮助的人持怀疑态度，因为我意识到其中一部分可能是伪造的，或者一部分可能是冒名顶替者。在某种程度上，这是否存在一种风险，即这会在总体上减少同情心的供给？
Yeah, I think certainly there is potentially that consequence. And I think this is one of the implications of the proliferation of victim signals is that because it's difficult to know exactly which ones are true or which ones are false, the more there are, the more likely some of them might be false, just in terms of sure probabilities. And those false ones will often be more prominent in people's minds. And yes, they will be then perhaps potentially more
是的，我认为这肯定会带来这种潜在的后果。我认为这也是受害者信号泛滥的后果之一，因为很难准确知道哪些是真的，哪些是假的，假信号越多，其中一些可能是假的概率就越高，纯粹从概率上讲。而这些虚假的信号往往会在人们心中更加突出。是的，他们将来可能会因此变得更加
vigilant in the future, or more skeptical, or less willing to indiscriminately offer their assistance in aid. I mean, I think that is one of the potential social welfare consequences of the increased signaling of victimhood. When we were children, many of us heard the story of the boy who cried wolf. He was a solitary shepherd with no one to talk to all day. So one day, he thought of a plan to amuse himself. He would call out that there was a wolf and watch the people in his village get riled up.
警惕，或者更加怀疑，或者不愿不分青红皂白地提供援助和帮助。我的意思是，我认为这是受害者身份信号增加带来的潜在社会福利后果之一。在我们小时候，许多人都听过“狼来了”的故事。他是一个孤独的牧羊人，整天没有人可以说话。所以有一天，他想出一个计划来取笑自己。他大喊有狼，并看着他村里的人变得群情激愤。
At first, this is exactly what happened. In the fable, the villagers heard the boys' shouts and came running to help. When they saw there was no wolf, they chastised the boy for lying to them. But far from learning his lesson, he tricked them a second time. The villagers realised they could not trust the boy. The next time he cried out for help, there really was a wolf. But by now, the villagers were tired of this game, and no one came to the boys' aid. As human beings, all of us depend upon the help of others. It can be tempting at times to exaggerate our suffering or to invent hardships in order
起初，事情确实如此。在寓言中，村民听到男孩的呼喊，跑来帮忙。当他们看到没有狼时，他们责备男孩对他们撒谎。但远未吸取教训的是，他又戏弄了他们第二次。村民们意识到他们不能信任这个男孩。下一次他呼救时，真的有一只狼。但此时此刻，村民们已经厌倦了这个游戏，没有人来帮助这个男孩。作为人类，我们所有人都依赖他人的帮助。有时，夸大我们的苦难或捏造苦难会让人感到很有诱惑力，
to elicit, compassion and aid. At such times, it's worth remembering that there is a steep price to be paid for crying wolf. That price isn't just paid by benefactors who are tricked into offering help when it isn't really needed. The burden falls disproportionately on the people who really do need help the most. When they discover, there is no compassion left for them. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's Executive Editor.
从而引发同情和援助。在这样的时刻，值得记住的是，“狼来了”是要付出沉重代价的。这个代价不仅仅由那些被哄骗在并不真正需要时提供帮助的恩人来承担。重担不成比例地落在了那些真正最需要帮助的人身上。当他们发现，再也没有同情留给他们时。“Hidden Brain”由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行主编。
We're always on the lookout for interesting stories that reveal the complexities of human nature. Have you ever done anything that makes you look back and say, why in the world did I do that? If you have a powerful personal story you are willing to share with a hidden brain audience, please record a short voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you have a powerful personal story about actions you took and perhaps regret with the benefit of hindsight, record a two or three minute voice memo outlining the story and email it to us at ideasathydnbrain.org. Please use the subject line, misgivings. We end the show today with a story from our sister's show, My Unsung Hero. It comes from Heather Church.
我们一直在寻找能够揭示人性复杂有趣的故事。你是否曾做过任何事，让你回首往事并说：我当时到底为什么要那样做？如果你有一个愿意与Hidden Brain听众分享的强有力的个人故事，请在手机上录制一则简短的语音备忘录，并将其通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次强调，如果你有一个强有力的个人故事，关于你所采取的行动以及事后诸葛亮般的遗憾，请录制一段两到三分钟的语音备忘录概述这个故事，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行：misgivings。今天节目的最后，我们带来一个来自我们姐妹秀“My Unsung Hero”的故事。它来自海瑟·丘奇。
show My Unsung Hero. It comes from Heather Church. Heather will never forget the day, many years ago, when she walked into a busy clothing store in New York City. When I went in there, I went down to the lower level, taking the stairs and wearing a very long skirt and a pair of boots. My skirt got caught on my boot. I had threw off my balance. I felt my hand reach for the railing and miss it and my body twisted as my boot tugged on my skirt. on my skirt. And suddenly I was falling down the stairs backwards. And then I heard steps, stumps, in fact, moving quickly towards me. And someone caught me. My head didn't hit those hard stairs, and I didn't suffer any injuries. And I don't know who that person is. That is my unsung hero. I don't know who they were, and I was so flustered at the time. I can't even remember their face, but I do remember what they did for me that day, and
节目“My Unsung Hero”。它来自海瑟·丘奇。海瑟永远不会忘记多年前的那个日子，当时她走进纽约市一家繁忙的服装店。当我走进去时，我走到了下层，走楼梯时穿着一条非常长的裙子和一双靴子。我的裙子卡在了靴子上。我失去了平衡。我感到我的手伸向栏杆却抓了个空，随着靴子扯动着我的裙子，我的身体扭曲了。扯动着我的裙子。突然我向后摔下楼梯。然后我听到脚步声，事实上是沉重的脚步声，正迅速向我移动。有人接住了我。我的头没有撞到那些坚硬的楼梯，我也没有受到任何伤害。我不知道那个人是谁。那就是我的无名英雄。我不知道他是谁，当时我太慌乱了。我甚至不记得他们的脸，但我确实记得那天他们为我所做的事，并且
I remain grateful. Thank you. Listener Heather Church from New York. She tells us that she hopes that stranger at the store might hear this episode and understand how much their actions continue to resonate with her all these years later. If you like this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you find our work to be useful in your life, do your part to help us thrive. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org.
我心存感激。谢谢。听众来自纽约的海瑟·丘奇。她告诉我们，她希望店里的那个陌生人能够听到这一集，并明白他们的行动在这么多年后仍然与她产生着多么强烈的共鸣。如果你喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次强调，如果你发现我们的工作对你的生活有益，请尽自己的一份力量帮助我们蓬勃发展。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。你 本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。